i don't agree with this whole vaccine
nonsense trucker lackey mcarthur doesn't
want the shot and a looming edict
barring unvaccinated cross-border work
won't change that there's plenty of
loads in canada i mean
i'll still be kept busy it just means
across border traffic well you're not
worried about leaving your job no
come saturday new rules mean
unvaccinated truckers entering canada
will be subject to testing and
quarantine
wednesday night the cbsa said canadian
truckers would be exempt late thursday
the health transport and public safety
minister said that information was
shared in error and there are no
exemptions for canadians confusion aside
the issue remains since the united
states has a similar policy which comes
into force a week later so really what
has to happen for relief in the supply
chain
is both ottawa and washington
need to move simultaneously everything
that you get comes by a truck so if we
have less drivers and less trucks on the
road
your stores aren't going to fill up as
fast existing driver shortages mean
there are already supply chain issues
removing thousands more from the
workforce will add pressure increasing
the rate per mile some companies have
been offering higher pay for
cross-border routes or incentives to get
vaccinated over the last few weeks we've
really worked really hard with our guys
to get them in help them get booked for
vaccines get them to where they need to
be to get a vaccination the vast
majority of truckers are vaccinated but
the true impact on the supply chain and
consumer prices won't be clear for a
while
abigail beeman global news ottawa